ومعنا من الجليل وديع عواوده الصحفي
والخبير بالشان الاسرائيلي قبل ان اسالك
انو لذا الخبر العاجل عن الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني سياره الاسعاف تعجز عن الوصول
الى المصابين في محافظه خان يونس السيد
عواوده اذا ما تابعنا ردود الفعل
التصريحات الاسرائيليه اليوم حول ما حدث
في المغازي كيف تقرا الربط بين صعوبه ما
حدث وعداله هذه الحرب وضروره مواصلتها
نعم تماما تحياتي لك زميله سهام وكل
المشاهدين يعني كانت مثل هذه الردود الفعل
التي توالت منذ الصباح هذا اليوم على لسان
الرئيس اسرائيل هيرتسوغ وتبعه عدد من
الوزراء اغلبيتهم كما قلت باتجاه محاوله
شد ازر الجيش محاوله رفع منسوب معنويات
الشارع الاسرائيلي بعد ه الضربه الموجعه
لوعي الاسرائيليين وهي تقول وتحذر من
امكانيه او يعني احتمال ان تتراجع عمليه
دعم الشارع الاسرائيلي لهذه الحرب في ظل
وجود شكوك كبيره ومتزايد حول جدواها
وحساباتها نظافه اعتباراتها واهليه هذه
الحكومه على ادارتها الى ماال ذلك من
الاسئله التي تحوم حول مجلس الحرب الى
اخره ولذلك هذه الضربه كبيره موجعه وتاتي
في اليوم الثامن التاسع بعد المئه من هذه
الحرب على غزه لتحدث فراغا كبيرا بين
الروايه الاسرائيليه المعلنه وبين الوقائع
على الارض وتحدث بطبيعه الحال ما يعرف
بعلم النفس بالتنافر المعرفي هذا ديسونس
كبير بالنسبه للاسرائيليين الروايه
الاسرائيليه تتحدث منذ شهور عن المكتسبات
والنجاحات وما ذلك حتى تاتي مثل هذه
العمليه وهي على بعد 600 متر فقط من
الحدود وليست في خانيونس وهناك طبعا
عمليات في خان يونس و الاثمان ترتفع هذه
التصريحات تاتي كمحاوله لمنع انهيار
الجبهه الداخليه في محاوله لمواصله هذه
الحكومه ايه الحرب على غزه علها تنقذ ماء
وجهها علها تحاول ان تحقق ما لم تحققه حتى
الان حتى يعني تخرج بشيء من الهيبه لا سما
وان هناك تساؤلات كبيره في اسرائيل وضغوط
كبيره في اسرائيل وكب وضغوط كبيره في
العالم من اجل وقف هذه الحرب طيب سيد
عواوده ما مدى
مصداقيه الجيش والحكومه الان في اسرائيل
بعد كل ما شهدناه في هذه الحرب وتحديدا
مواقف معينه كانت فيها كان فيها تضارب
وتناقض بين الروايه الرسميه وبين الوقائع
على
الارض نعم انا اعتقد هذه الحادثه وان كانت
حلقه في مسلسل الاحداث ولكنها الاكبر
الاخطر ولذلك عناوين الاعلام الاسرائيلي
هذا النهار ومنذ ساعات المساء حيث كانت
تصل تسريبات بان هناك حدثا امنيا جللا في
قطاع غزه
ماساويه هذه العناوين تتحدث عن اليوم
الاصعب في تاريخ الحرب ولذلك يعني السؤال
الفوري الكبير حول مفاعيل مثل هذه الحادثه
والمخفي فيها اعظم هناك احاديث الان عن
وجود اعداد اكبر من 21 قتيل وجريح في قطاع
غزه في اليوم الفائد وا السؤال كيف سينعكس
ذلك على مصير الحرب على احتجاجات العائلات
واحتجاجات ومظاهرات من يناصر ومن يريد
الان وقف الحرب واعطاء فرصه لاستعاده
المحتجزين كهدف اول حتى وان كانت الحرب قد
توقفت بدون ان تحقق اهدافها العاليه وهناك
اوساط متزايده في اسرائيل تذهب بهذا
الاتجاه والسؤال التالي كيف سينعكس لاحقا
على وعي الاسرائيليين ونضوج هذه المسيره
مسيره الوعي بان الحلول العسكريه العصى
الغليظه التي تستخدمها اسرائيل مع
الفلسطينيين ليست مجديه وان هناك حاجه
للبحث عن حلول سياسيه وان السلام العرب لا
ي لا يكفل لا الامن ولا الامان ولا
الاطمئنان لاسرائيل انما الحل هو بالسلام
مع الفلسطينيين هكذا تقول صحيفه هارث في
افتتاحيتها ويقى السؤال اذا ما كانت مثل
هذه العمليات ستدفع نحو نضوج وعي اسرائيلي
يدفع الى نهايه هذه الحرب الخروج من هذه
الحرب البحث عن سلم وبدايه مسيره نضوج وعي
طويله للتسليم بالامر الواقع والذهاب الى
تسويه اكفل كرامه الفلسطينيين الوطنيه
والحقوق الا الاساسيه الحقوق الحد الادى
من حقوق الفلسطينيين انا اعتقد ان هذا هو
الاتجاه وهذا موط بكثير من العوامل الاخرى
صمود المقاومه الفلسطينيه استمرار هذا
النزيف الاقتصادي استمرار الضغوط الداخليه
من قبل عائلات المحتجزين واستمرار هذا
النزيف داخل مجلس الحرب هذه الاختلافات
هذه الفضائح التي تتسرب من مجلس الحرب
الذي كان قدس اقداس اسرائيل لم يكن هناك
حرب في اسرائيل تسربت فيها مثل هذه الكميه
من المعلومات الفضائح من مجلس الحرب كل
ذلك من شانه من شان هذه العمليه ان تكون
عاملا دافعا لنضوج تيار يدفع موجه اكبر
تدفع الحكومه نحو انهاء هذه الحرب و ما
طبيعه هذا التيار يعني ما الجهات التي
يمكن فعلا الان في اسرائيل ان ان تشكل ما
تقول عنه من نضج يدفع في اتجاه تغيير على
الاقل جيه اسرائيل في هذه
الحرب نعم الكلفه الباهظه وان تاتي هذه
الضربه الموجعه بعد هذا بعد فتره طويله
وفي ظل احاديث اسرائيليه عن مكتسبات
ونجاحات وما الى ذلك شعور الاسرائيليين
الشارع الاسرائيلي بان هذه الحرب بلا افق
بلا نهايه وان حسابات نتنياهو وحسابات هذه
الحكومه المتطرفه التي قال عنها بايدن
والذي يعرف نفسه كصه وي بان هذه الحكومه
الاكثر تطرفا في تاريخ اس اسرائيل هذه
الشكوك في الشارع الاسرائيلي بان هذه حرب
لخدمه نتنياهو وهذا الائتلاف اكثر من هي
خدمه الاسرائيليين في ظل خطر حقيقي وقلق
حقيقي على مصير وحياه المحتجزين في ظل
استمرار هذا النزيف هذه الخسائر الموجعه
لاسرائيل من جرحه وقتله بالاضافه ل كما
قلنا الاثمان الاقتصاديه وغيرها الضغوط
الاخرى في الداخل كل ذلك من شانه ان يدفع
عمليا ان كنت تسالين عن ما هو محدد انا
اعتقد ان هذا سيشك الباب عاجلا اجلا امام
خروج ايزن كوت وانس من الحكومه وهذا اذان
ببدء موجه احتجاج اوسع وا جدوى